Okay,
as I mentioned,
I'm at Washington University,
which is in St Louis.
It's actually quite a beautiful city.
I moved there from Oakland,
California was the place I had lived
before that and moving.
They're having only lived on both sides
of the country and never in the middle
and I guess moving in particular to the
city really opened my eyes to some of
the systemic racism that was apparent in
the city.
It's a great place and it also has a big
divide,
in fact locally,
and I'm not sure if this goes on outside
of the city as well.
It's often referred to as the divided
city and there's even a line that
demarcates where that divide takes
place.
I live one block from that line and I
was seeing regularly,
um,
all kinds of things happened that were
really eyeopening to me.
Okay.
I think that the country's eyes got
opened even wider after Ferguson and
many other events that continue to
happen around the country.
I mean,
as a developmental psychologist,
I really took a lot of this to heart
because I was thinking about my kids and
the kids that I was seeing in my lab and
those kids that weren't coming into my
lab and then I know that lived across
that line and what should we,
could we potentially be doing both for
the kids,
but also looking at kids with some hope
for the future.
Now what we do know,
um,
sadly in children is that they're
already has implicit biases that you can
pick up and observing kids at five to
six years of age.
This is one example of a study that my
colleague Melanie killen did.
She is at University of Maryland,
so close to Baltimore.
And what she found is that different
children will interpret this scene,
these scenes very differently.
Okay.
And what she discovered in,
in this particular study is that black
kids actually are much more optimistic
about race than white kids already by
first grade,
which is the kid she tested in this
study.
The white kids were having much more
negative or pessimistic kinds of
interpretations than the black children
who are trying to have much more
positive interpretation and
interpretation that's positive,
for example,
will be like,
oh,
it looks like he fell off the off the
swing and the other kid was waiting to
see if he needed help.
Um,
a not so positive interpretation would
be something like,
I think he pushed him off the swing so
that he could use it.
Okay.
So what we were thinking about is how
might we go ahead and take action and be
looking at the kids,
what could we do earlier?
Are we already seeing that these biases
are developing already in the preschool
years?
What might we be doing?
Um,
other ways that we could step in and
intervene on this.
Okay.
So we know that babies notice
differences between people of all kinds.
Whether people speak different
languages,
have different color skin act
differently.
We also know that by three years of age,
children are already noticing power and
status differences and that by five or
six years of age,
as I said,
we're already seeing implicit biases
about these.
What is happening in the preschool
years,
and we wanted to ask a few questions.
I'm only going to show you two things
that we've been looking at this.
Okay.
Now our participants are.
Our kids that are in these studies are
at preschools all over the city of St
Louis.
I'm going to report today data that's
coming from kids that are on in racially
homogenous schools,
so their schools that are mostly all
black kids and black teachers or mostly
all white kids and white teachers,
but we're also testing at a number of
mixed schools that are in the city.
Most of the kids in the homogenous
schools also come from a pretty
homogenous neighborhoods of both races
and we put them in these two tasks,
accuracy task,
which is just having somebody named
those three objects and either saying
them accurately.
It's a cup,
it's a ball and it's a book or naming
them wrong inaccurately.
It's a pencil.
It's a fork and it's a shoe.
Okay,
and what we see in lots and lots of
studies previously by many colleagues of
mine and myself,
is that children prefer the person who
is accurate and they also refer to learn
from that person.
So we wanted to ask them,
here is all we did was change out the
race of one of these speakers and ask
them which one of these people would you
like to have as your teacher can.
We did that in accuracy tasks.
So one of these was always accurate and
one wasn't okay.
Then we also put them into a simple
teacher preference task.
We didn't give them any background
information.
We just asked which of these would you
like to have is your teacher.
And these were always different people.
I think I may have put the same faces
up,
but they're always different.
And what we found in these racially
homogenous schools is that both white
and black children were.
They wanted an accurate person to teach
them stuff and to be their teacher.
So it didn't matter.
Black,
white,
they wanted the accurate person.
That's who they wanted to be their
teacher.
However,
when we simply asked them,
which one of these people do you prefer
to be your teacher?
Both races have kids preferred the white
teacher.
I'll leave that there for a minute just
to sync.
These are three to six year old kids
now.
We also put them in a marshmallow task
with Eshkol range,
which has long been used to look at how
kids delay gratification.
That has all kinds of successful
outcomes,
but we wanted to look at something else
more recently.
Some findings have suggested that you
might get different effects in this
marshmallow test depending on how much
you trust that the speaker is going to
come back.
Okay,
so we wanted to use this as sort of a
measure of trust in the speaker and what
we did is present put kids again,
black or white kids,
and the only difference between them was
whether they got a black experimenter or
the wide experiment to do the
marshmallow task with them and this is
all they are.
They're sat down at a table in a room.
You're given a big,
enticing marshmallow and they're told
just wait,
I'm going to be back and if you don't
eat that before I get back,
I'm going to actually give you another
marshmallow so you'll have to buy and
they leave the room.
They're being filmed in there,
so we see what's going on and we know
how long they waited and what we found
again is that black waited exactly same
amount of time.
Didn't matter if the experimenter was
white or black.
The white kids,
we did significantly longer if the
experimenter was white.
Okay.
Both of these things suggest to us that
there is already something going on
starting at three years of age and up
and that there's a lot of work that
needs to be done to the snip these in
the bud while we still have these kids
before other things can be happening.
Okay?
Um,
now we are testing at mixed race
schools.
I'm hoping that some of this will come
out a little bit differently,
but we will learn from that and see what
exposure and interaction can do.
We do know that cross race friendship is
one of the best predictors of a lessened
bias across races and other social
groups.
Okay.
Quickly because I know I need to wrap
up.
I just want to present this idea that
what it must be like I'm in a world and
what if kids,
when when you are a minority and
everything isn't presented to look like
you.
This is what a black child typically
feels like when they go to the store to
pick her doll or when they go to the
bookstore to look at books,
looking for examples of things that
represent me,
that are like me,
that I can relate with,
that I can learn from and relate to.
And so what if white kids had that same
kind of understanding and it gave them a
better way or a more clear view of what
the world was like.
Okay.
Now there is one such organization that
I've been really lucky to partner with
in St Louis.
It's called stories and stories.
Is is introducing white families and
mixed race families to um,
more diverse books and helping parents
have conversations about race in their
home.
A black families tend to have much more
conversation about race because they
need to then white families that tend to
have difficulty talking about these
issues with their kids even if they're
well intended and want to.
It's challenging so they're giving them
the books and the resources with which
to do this.
And this is already really taking fire
and there's a huge wait list.
They've already worked with I think 500
and something families in the St Louis
area and there's 400 or so families,
at least on the waitlist.
They can't move along as fast as I can.
So I've partnered with them both as
member in the program,
but also I'm doing some of the research
to see the effect of exposure,
um,
through diverse exposure to diversity
through books.
If that can have any kind of impact and
change.
One important thing about this program
is that not only is as opposed to impact
the kids,
but it already has and we see the
effects of it impacting the parents so
that parents caring about this,
it's making them much more committed to
seeing change in the region and making
sure that their kids grow up thinking
differently.
I'll leave you soon with a quote from
Baldwin who said that I can't be a
pessimist because I'm alive.
To be a pessimist means that you have
agreed that human life is an academic
matter.
So I'm forced to be an optimist.
I'm forced to believe that we can
survive whatever it is we must survive.
Okay?
But we don't have to survive everything.
Some of the things we need to figure out
and we can change them.
I really have.
I'm having the audacity of hope for
racial equity,
uh,
to keep moving forward.
And I want to leave with this quote,
which is,
um,
when I was struggling not only with the
things that were going on in my city,
around me,
but then the,
uh,
campaigns and elections last year.
Sometimes I say,
why should we do anything?
There's no hope.
There's,
and this gave me some hope,
actually some optimism.
And if you can't read it,
there's one of his little creatures that
saying,
why so optimistic?
About 2017.
What do you think it will bring?
The other one says,
I think it will bring flowers.
Yes.
How come?
Because I am planting flowers and what
optimism can do is give us the faith
that eventually takes us to seeing some
improvement to seeing some achievement.
Okay.
Nothing is going to be able to be done
without the ability for us to be able to
imagine what isn't there,
how things could be changed or imagine
the ways in which things aren't already.
And that requires hope.
So for hope and optimism.
Um,
this is my view of how these come
together.
And I ask that you planted lots of
flowers.